telle a été la solitaire en direct sur
notre antenne et c'est une première
la déclaration du gouvernement au
parlement sur le projet de programme de
stabilité européen
ce texte contient les prévisions et les
engagements de la france en matière de
réduction des déficits publics et de la
dette publique
il sera ensuite transmis à la commission
européenne à mes côtés pour en parler
jean arthuis bonsoir président de la
commission des finances
ici au sénat c'est donc une première le
parlement va donc débattre de ce
programme et ensuite se prononcer par un
vote
est-ce que c'était devenu une nécessité
démocratique cette nouvelle procédure
certainement et c'est sans doute la fin
du double langage
la convention était que chaque année le
gouvernement adressait à la commission
de bruxelles un programme de stabilité
qui à chaque fois sur une période de
trois à quatre ans aboutissent et un
relatifs équilibre des finances
publiques
cette prévision ne s'est jamais vérifié
le discours
c'était donc une prévision rigoureuse
mais qui ne se vérifiait pas et au plan
national on avait des discours plus
incommode dans ce document qu était
transmis à bruxelles qu est l engagement
de la france ne passait pas devant le
parlement
et bien c'est une première c'est une
conquête pour le parlement pour la
première fois le parlement va se
prononcer sur une déclaration du
gouvernement sur une prévision sur un
programme de stabilité transmis à
bruxelles
j'observe que nous entrons dans le
semestre budgétaire européen désormais
compte tenu de la situation des finances
publiques en europe
les partenaires vont devoir adresser
leurs prévisions budgétaires
la commission se prononcera examinera
expertisera et puis au mois de juin nous
aurons connaissance des observations
éventuelles de la commission et ce
document reviendra devant le parlement
je tiens à ce qu'au sénat nous puissions
avoir l'occasion de prendre connaissance
de ses observations et d'exprimer une
résolution qui sera soumise à un vote
parce que ce type de nouvelles
procédures auraient pu empêcher ce qu'on
a connu la grèce à savoir la
présentation de comptes publics
truqué ou falsifiés probablement en tout
cas la gouvernance européenne a été
laxiste au nom du respect de la
souveraineté nationale
chaque état membre était supposé
communiquer des documents sincère or
manifestement nos partenaires grecs ne
respecte pas respectez pas cette
sincérité et c'est une lacune européenne
que de ne pas avoir pris les moyens
d'examiner d'expertisé de bousculer un
peu la souveraineté nationale car
aujourd'hui la grèce c'est en risque de
défaut de paiement dans une situation
budgétaire mans plus que préoccupante
il faut venir en aide à la grèce et pour
venir en aide aux partenaires grecs faut
avoir l'assurance qu'il a pris de bonnes
résolutions
aytus que ce qui vient de se produire ne
va pas se reproduire demain car ce sont
ceux qui ont fait des efforts qui
doivent aujourd'hui mettent la main à la
poche pour venir en aide à ceux qui ont
été quelque peu laxiste alors nous avons
un devoir collectif de surveillance
mutuelle
si on revient à la situation française
pour respecter ce pacte de stabilité
européen la france doit réduire son
déficit public à 3% du pib
on en est encore loin l'état doit donc
faire un effort à la fois sur les
dépenses et les recettes pour vous la
commission des finances du sénat vous
chiffré cet effort entre 6 et 10
milliards d'euros sur quoi cet effort
doit-il porter en priorité à la fois sur
les recettes et sur les dépenses c'est
vrai que le gouvernement un prêt une
hypothèse de croissance volontariste
excessivement optimiste il est à
craindre qu'elle ne soit pas respecté
depuis dix ans la croissance est de
l'ordre de 1,5 1,6 en moyenne
comment peut-on aujourd'hui passé à 2,5
alors que certaines réformes visant à
redonner de la compétitivité aux travail
à l'économie n'ont pas été mises en
oeuvre
donc soyons prudents et cette prudence
dans l'estimation des recettes doit se
fonder sur une prévision de l'ordre de
2% est plus raisonnable donc essayer le
prévisionnel de la commission des
finances une croissance à 2% faut se
préparer à des efforts sans doute en
gommant d'autres niches fiscales pour
que l'état perçoit plus de ressources
et puis en faisant pression à nouveau
sur la dépense publique il faut à la
fois père pression sur la dépense et
être conscient qu'il faudra bien pour
équilibrer les finances publiques ont
augmenté légèrement les impôts disons ne
plus accorder des dépenses fiscales qui
sont la mauvaise herbe fiscales les
niches
merci jean arthuis je vous laisse donc
eux regagné l'hémicycle du sénat où va
donc débuter la déclaration du
gouvernement j'accueille à présent
nicole bricq qui est la vice présidente
socialiste de la commission des finances
du sénat venait à mes côtés et nicole
bricq bonsoir alors donc c'est une
première ce vote est ce que le programme
qui vous est soumis et potentiel vous
pourriez potentiellement le voter ah non
je crains que nous ne puissions pas le
faire pour la bonne raison que il repose
sur une hypothèse macroéconomique
délibérément manifestement optimiste la
ministre annonce pour 2012 année
électorale comme on le sait un chiffre
de 2 25% alors que les conjoncturistes
s'accordent plus tôt
r 1 8% alors c'est très important
l'hypothèse macro économique si elle est
exagérément optimiste ça posera la
question que nous avions déjà posé
l'année dernière si la croissance est
moins forte et bien comment fait-on
comment on fait le gouvernement est ce
qu'ils continuent à comprimer la dépense
ou est ce qu'il augmente les
prélèvements obligatoires du côté
recettes c'est la réponse à la question
nous ne l'avons pas donc ça nuit à
l'hypothèse de crédibilité et cet
exercice dans la forme qui est commun à
tous les pays de la zone euro finalement
va'a
jouer sur la dépense donc sur une
austérité au niveau de la zone euro la
condamnant finalement à une croissance
faible
donc il ya un effet multiplicateur
concernant à la fois à la perte de
service public
le gel par exemple de l' indice des
fonctionnaires va entraîner un petit
crowe dans la dans la consommation de
ces ménages donc et en même temps le
gouvernement comprime la dépense ce qui
pèse sur l'économie fait une hypothèse
hasardeuse de croissance et ne joue pas
du tout sur le volet recettes parce que
il ne veut pas affiché une hausse est
impopulaire à l'approché de la
présidentielle
le volailler il veut pas affiché une
hausse des prélèvements obligatoires
bien que déjà avec la loi de finances
pour 2011
il ya eu une augmentation et on est
revenu au même niveau que en 2007 avant
la crise et on se rend compte que la
promesse qu'avait faite le président de
la république au début de son mandat de
baisser les prélèvements obligatoires de
quatre points évidemment ne sera pas
tenu de la même manière que la
croissance qu'il devait aller chercher
avec les dents ne sera pas au rendez
vous n'est pas au rendez vous donc le
gouvernement fait un peu comme si tous
les clignotants de l'économie étaient au
vert
et à partir de là il n'y a pas de
crédibilité à cet exercice qui vous
allez voter contre c'est ce qu'on va
voir la séance a débuté voilà c'est à
dire que nous pas de crédibilité de
l'hypothèse macroéconomique aucune
action sur le volontariste sur le volet
recettes et je pense notamment aux
nombreuses niches fiscales qui sont
évalués dans la période la plus récente
à 100 milliards d'euros
je rappelle que le parti socialiste dans
l'engagement qu'il a pris à partir de
2012 de jouer sur les niches fiscales à
hauteur de 50 milliards d'euros
et quand même plus réaliste que nous les
le gouvernement alors s'il s'agit et
madame lagarde a dit elle va nous le
répéter qu'il fallait absolument que la
france garde le triple à
donc ça veut dire que cet exercice
commun à tous les pays de la zone euro
se fait certainement sous l'oeil des
marchés financiers en revanche il ne se
fait pas dans la clarté sous l'oeil des
peuples merci nicole bricq on va vous
laisser regagné l'hémicycle du sénat car
la séance a débuté et on écoute tout de
suite christine lagarde la ministre de
l'économie
méditez budgétaire à réduire le chômage
par des réformes du marché du travail a
déployé de nouveaux efforts afin de
renforcer la croissance tous les états
membres traduiront ses priorités en
mesures concrètes qu'ils incluront dans
leurs programmes de stabilité ou de
convergence et leurs programmes
nationaux de réforme
nous sommes là quelques mois plus tard
et c'est à l'occasion donc de ce conseil
du 25 mars que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ont décidé d'aller au delà
de ce simple pacte de stabilité et de
croissance qui nous amène à regarder
essentiellement le compteur du déficit
le compteur de la dette
aller au delà et à s'appliquer
précisément à définir ensemble un cadre
macroéconomique à définir ensemble des
objectifs de compétitivité et à
syndiquer les uns les autres quels
moyens nous mettons au service de ses
politiques
l'objectif de ce semestre européen est
donc double d'une part l'organisation de
débats au premier semestre sur les
programmes de stabilité et de
convergence et sur les programmes de
réformes structurelles qui permettra
ainsi une meilleure coordination en
amont de nos politiques économiques
c'est en effet pleinement le sens du
débat que nous avons aujourd'hui à
bruxelles
c'est également d'ailleurs pour
information et je le livre à la haute
assemblée
ce sont exactement les mêmes termes du
débat que nous avons actuellement au
sein du g20 pour permettre de non
seulement coordonner nos politiques
économiques avoir les mêmes analyses les
mêmes approches mais surtout nous
assurer que les politiques économiques
que nous mettons en oeuvre dans nos
régions respectives dans nos étangs et
bien son nom seulement propice à nos
intérêts nationaux mais sont également
propices et positive à l'égard des
intérêts des autres états qui
participent à cette à cette même
économie mondiale qui est aujourd'hui à
l'oeuvre
voilà pour ces quelques mots
d'introduction en matière de semestre
européen et en matière de démarches que
nous appliquons a non seulement une zone
monétaire un pacte de stabilité et de
croissance mais également un pacte de
compétitivité et de convergence qui nous
amène donc à comparer à évaluer à
mesurer les effets internes mais
également les effets externes ce qu'on
appelle les fameuses spill over en
jargon économique type g20 type fonds
monétaire international pour nous
assurer de la meilleure efficacité des
politiques que nous déterminons quelques
mots maintenant sur le cadrage
macroéconomique que nous avons retenu je
vous rappelle qu'à l'occasion de la
clôture des comptes france de l'année
2010 nous avons pu constater que
l'économie française a repris le chemin
de la croissance puisque la croissance
confirmée par les chiffres de l'insee
s'est élevé à 1 25% conformément à la
prévision inscrite dans le programme de
stabilité de janvier 2010 et dans le
projet de loi de finances pour 2011 la
croissance n'est plus seulement
maintenant alimenté par différents plans
de relance les nôtres et ceux qui
avaient été impulsée par les états
voisins avec lesquels nous commerçons
elle est plus autonome
elle est alimentée essentiellement plus
par l'investissement privé que par
l'investissement public est également
toujours par la consommation des ménages
qui n'a jamais fléchi en france durant
aucun trimestre depuis le début de la
crise financière puis économique qui a
frappé notre pays pour l'année 2011 je
maintient la prévision de 2% identique à
celle du projet de loi de finances pour
2011 nous avons tenu compte évidemment
d'un certain nombre de facteurs des
facteurs négatifs des facteurs positifs
au titre des facteurs négatifs on peut
retenir bien entendu la hausse du prix
des matières premières pas seulement
celle des produits pétroliers mais
également celle d'un certain nombre
d'autres matières premières je pense
également aux matières premières
agricoles
ce cette prise en compte de la hausse
des matières premières nous amener à
relever notre prévision d'inflation de
1,5 à 1,8 pour cent pour l'année 2011
deuxième facteur qui présente à la fois
du négatif et du positif c'est le niveau
plus élevé de l'euro qu'à l'époque à
laquelle nous avons procédé à nos
premières prévisions
ce niveau élevé de l'euro bien entendu à
un effet que l'on peut considérer comme
négatifs pour ceux des exportateurs qui
ont leurs bases coûts en euros elle a
évidemment un effet positif dès lors
qu'il s'agit de régler un certain nombre
de factures
je pense notamment aux factures
énergétiques dès lors que ces produits
là sont eux vendus et côté en valeur
dollar troisième aspect négatif qui
vient évidemment impacté l'année 2011 et
nos prévisions c'est la situation
catastrophique de l'économie japonaise
frappés par les les catastrophes
naturelles et leur succès d'année au
cours des dernières semaines et qui
amène non seulement cette économie à
fléchir d'un montant qui varie entre 1 5
et 3 % selon les estimations des
différents économistes mais qui a aussi
pour effet et bien de tahrir ou de
devoir trouver des sources alternatives
aux approvisionnements qui sont
nécessaires à nos chaînes de fabrication
sur un certain nombre de produits
notamment des produits électroniques
stratégique dans la série des plus
puisque là nous abordions l'est moins
dans la série des plus pour l'année 2011
on peut considérer d'abord que le
chiffre de créations d'emplois pour
l'année 2010 le rappel 125 mille
créations nettes d'emplois pour l'année
2011 une prévision révisée par l'insee a
pratiquement 80 mille créations nettes
d'emplois dont je vous indique au
passage d'ailleurs que le chiffre le
plus récent en matière d'emploi qui date
d'il y a à peu près quelques minutes
indiquent que au titre du mois de
février le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
a baissé de 0 8% soit un peu plus de
vingt mille demandeurs d'emploi en moins
ce qui confirme ainsi les tendances que
nous observons maintenant depuis l'année
2010 et qui semble conforter à nouveau
par ces chiffres du mois de février
deuxième aspect positif ce sont
évidemment les enquêtes de conjoncture
enquêtes de conjoncture qui sont
réalisés par l'insee auprès des chefs
d'entreprise et qui indique que la
plupart d'entre eux ont une appréciation
positive voire très positive
non seulement pour leur carnet de
commandes mais pour leurs prévisions de
reconstitution de stocks et pour la
prévision d'activité sur
l'année 2011 est tout particulièrement
sur le premier semestre
en étant seul a conforté par les
révisions de prévisions qui ont été
effectués par l' ocde au titre à la fois
du premier semestre et de l'ensemble de
l'année 2011 puisque l' ocde prévoit et
bien une relèvement à +0 9 et +0 7 au
titre des deux c2 semestre
la prévision de l'insee étant également
révisée elle aussi a plus 0,6 pour le
premier semestre et maintenu à +0 carte
pour le deuxième je parle des trimestre
pardon t1 t2 troisième aspect positif
c'est évidemment la consommation des
ménages qui je le disais tout à l'heure
n'a pas fléchi depuis le début de la
crise mesuré en trimestre et qui pour
l'instant en dépit d'un certain nombre
de craintes qu'on aurait pu avoir en
particulier à raison de la cessation de
la prime à la casse en particulier qui
est demeurent bien orientés qui contenu
qui continuent à soutenir durablement la
croissance française
l'ensemble de ces facteurs négatifs et
positifs tante de mon point de vue à
s'équilibrer et cela justifie
parfaitement me semble-t-il que nous
maintenions notre prévision de
croissance à 2%
nous sommes en cela rejoint d'ailleurs
par la révision de croissance qui a été
effectué par l' ocde
il y a maintenant quelques semaines et
qui prévoit pour la france une
augmentation de la croissance de 22 2%
voire un peu plus de 2%
l'activité devrait accélérer pendant
cette année 2011
en vertu de quoi en vertu d'une part du
mouvement des exportations dont je vous
rappelle que sur les six derniers mois
il augmente au même rythme que les
exportations allemandes
deuxièmement grâce à l'investissement
investissements aussi bien des
entreprises que des ménages
les chefs d'entreprise des industries
manufacturières très voir je rappelais
tout à l'heure les enquêtes de
conjoncture de l'insee prévoit une
augmentation de leurs investissements de
l'ordre de 14% sur l'année 2011
je crois que la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle et l'incitation à
l'investissement en équipements et biens
mobiliers sur le territoire français est
en train de produire ses effets j'ajoute
puisqu'il s'agit d'un indicateur qui est
souvent utilisé à et souvent pertinent
également que
le nombre des permis de construire qui a
été donc mis en demande est telle qu'il
est mesuré au mois de mars est en
augmentation lui sur une période de 12
mois de 17%
troisième facteur de nature à lui aussi
soutenir l'activité pendant l'année 2011
qui sera un troisième moteur de cette
activité c'est le cycle des stocks
on s'aperçoit quand on interroge les
chefs d'entreprise que le niveau de
leurs stocks et bas qu'ils n'ont qu'ils
ont très peu reconstituée pendant
l'année 2000 en 2010 contrairement à un
certain nombre de pays voisins notamment
l'allemagne et que par conséquent nous
allons assister pendant le début de
l'année 2011 à un mouvement de
reconstitution des stocks qui sera
important enfin dernier facteur qui l'a
aussi va constituer un moteur de
croissance ce sont les créations nettes
d'emplois dont je vous le rappelle
l'insee a chiffré le volume pour le
premier semestre à peu passent
pratiquement 80 milles et dont nous
espérons en tout cas qu'il sera
nettement supérieur à celui de l'année
2010 où je vous rappelle l'économie
française a créé plus 125 mille emplois
nets au cours de l'exercice
concernant 2012 sur l'année 2012
eh bien je prévois une croissance qui
sera ramenée à 2 25% d'eau qui sera
porté à 2,25 pour cent puisque
conviendra de 2% en 2011 l'activité
s'accélérer grâce à la dynamique de
l'investissement et grâce à la poursuite
de l'amélioration du marché du travail
elles accélérera également grâce à un
certain nombre des réformes
structurelles que nous avons engagé
depuis 2008 je le rappelle crédit impôt
recherche investissements d'avenir
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
réforme des retraites qui tout devrait
contribuer à renforcer la croissance
je rappelle en particulier qu'en ce qui
concerne la réforme des retraites nous
prévoyons que sur une période de 10 ans
son impact direct sur la croissance est
mesurée à 0 3% par année
pour autant les incertitudes pesant sur
l'investissement international nous as
it a révisé légèrement puisque nous
avions prévu initialement une croissance
de 2 5% qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans
d'autres prévisions et d'autres
documents d'autres partis cette
prévision de croissance pour 2012 est
légèrement plus prudentes qu'auparavant
je les rabaisser de 0,25 pour cent
d'une part parce que le pétrole se situe
un taux qui est nettement plus élevé que
le taux auquel nous avions fait nos
prévisions initiales
et puis d'autre part parce que les
crises qui sont liées au phénomène de
dettes souveraines et de difficultés de
refinancement d'un certain nombre
d'états pas seulement d'ailleurs en
europe entraînera sans aucun doute un
effort de consolidation budgétaire
importants en europe mais ailleurs
également ce qui tendra probablement à
diminuer le volume de la demande qui est
adressée à la france par l'étranger
troisième et dernier point je voudrais
vous indiquer à quel point il me paraît
indispensable il nous paraît
indispensable que la france respecte sa
trajectoire des finances publiques le
déficit public 2010 s'est révélée moins
élevé que prévu nous avions initialement
prévu 2006 8,5 puis 8,2 puis plus
récemment 7,7 -7 7% 7 ce chiffre a été
ramené vous le savez à 7% ce qui nous
permet de rajuster là aussi la prévision
du déficit pour l'année 2010 à 5 7% et
non pas 6 % comme initialement envisagé
je laisserais bien sûr à françois baroin
le soin de détailler la trajectoire de
notre déficit je veux simplement ici
rappeler l'engagement très ferme du
gouvernement à respecter quoi qu'il
arrive cette trajectoire
quelles que soient les conditions
économiques
notre programme de stabilité prévoit un
ajustement structurel total sur la
période 2010 2013 supérieure à 4 points
de produit intérieur brut
c'est la demande qui nous avaient été
adressées par nos partenaires européens
c'est l'engagement que nous avons pris
également vis-à-vis d'eux je veux redire
également l'attachement de notre
gouvernement à faire porter l'effort
particulier pour diminuer lé déficit sur
la réduction de la défend de la dépense
plutôt que sur l'augmentation de la
recette bien sûr et cette maîtrise des
dépenses elle passe par un certain
nombre de choix au premier rang desquels
la double norme qui est celle selon
laquelle les dépenses totales ne
progressent pas plus vite que
l'inflation et les dépenses hors
intérêts du service de la dette et hors
pensions des fonctionnaires soient
stabilisés en euros constants elle
repose également sur un objectif
ambitieux l'objectif national de
dépenses d'assurance maladie le fameux
l'ondam qui est abaissé de
un point en 2011 puis de nouveau en 2012
pour se stabiliser à plus de 8 par an je
voudrais simplement ici souligné que
pour la première fois le pays a tenu son
objectif en dames et je crois que ça a
été vivement appréciée dans un certain
nombre de cercles notamment d'analystes
financiers
la réforme des retraites de 2010
contribuera également à la maîtrise des
dépenses sur la période sa montée en
charge rapide permettra en fait de
réduire le déficit public de 0,5 point
de pib dès 2013 je vous rappelle donc
une double contribution de cette réforme
absolument déterminante
d'abord la réduction du déficit public
de 0,5 à partir de 2013 et
l'augmentation de la croissance ou
simplement parce qu'il y a plus de
travail dans l'économie en période
moyenne calculée sur une période de dix
ans de 0,3 pour cent nous allons
poursuivre l'effort de réduction des
niches fiscales et sociales nous
maintenons notre engagement de
suppression des niches fiscales et
sociales conformément au rythme qui
avait été inscrit dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
c'est à dire pour un montant plancher de
11 milliards d'euros sur l'exercice 2011
et 3 milliards par an par la suite nous
supprimerons en priorité les niches les
moins efficaces d'un point de vue
socio-économique
les recettes seront spontanément soutenu
par le rebond de l'activité
les finances publiques bénéficieront de
l'intensification de la reprise
économique
d'autant plus que la solidité du système
bancaire français est le niveau
relativement bas de l'endettement des
ménages permettront d'envisager une
reprise plus dynamique que chez un
certain nombre de nos partenaires qui
devront consacrer une partie de leurs
efforts budgétaires probablement à la
restructuration de ces secteurs
dans ce contexte les recettes publiques
devraient spontanément progresser un peu
plus vite que l'activité économique en
raison de leur retour progressif à la
normale après une très forte baisse
observée en 2009
ainsi le programme table sur une
élasticité moyenne des prélèvements
obligatoires ropib légèrement supérieur
à l'unité sur la période 2011 2014
la dette publique à partir de 2013
commencera à véritablement s'infléchir
elle connaîtra une poursuite de sa
progression sur les exercices 2011 et
ce ratio de dette augmentera en effet de
2.9 est de 1.5 sur les exercices 2011 et
et à partir de 2013 et bien notre
trajectoire de finances publics
garantira un déficit d'exécution
inférieur au sol de théorique
stabilisant la dette et on s'aperçoit
ensuite en poursuivant les prévisions
qu'on a une diminution très rapide du
volume de notre dette
en conclusion le programme de stabilité
que nous proposons de soumettre à la
commission européenne s'inscrit dans la
double logique d'abord de renforcer la
stratégie de consolidation budgétaire à
laquelle nous appelle tout simplement
notre responsabilité avec pour objectif
de ramener à 3% de déficit dès 2013
il ya 2% en 2014 et bien sûr à nous
focaliser sur l'amélioration de la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
de l'économie française en général par
une accentuation d'un certain nombre des
dépenses que nous consacrons à
l'économie française sur les secteurs
privilégiés indispensable de la
recherche et du développement je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur françois baroin ministre du
budget des comptes publics de la
fonction publique et de la réforme de
l'état porte-parole du gouvernement
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chaque christine monsieur le président
la commission des finances monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
européennes monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
cette présentation intervient comme l'a
évoqué que si la garde dans le cadre du
nouveau calendrier qui institue sur
rendez vous avant que le programme ne
soit transmis aux institutions
européennes
je veux faire partager
au sénat cet important changement cette
étape d'une certaine manière décisive
dans l'organisation que la france va
formaliser à travers les deux positions
qu'elle va défendre les engagements
qu'elle va prendre et que ce couple
exécutif législatif réunis soit
l'occasion pour chacun de mesurer
combien la signature france est à
travers le débat qui nous anime un
élément prioritaire pour les politiques
publiques que nous portons au nom de nos
compatriotes caisse il n'a gardé
d'évoquer si nos finances publiques
portent toujours les stigmates de la
récession mondiale une amélioration
notable peut d'ores et déjà être
constatée je ne reviens pas sur les
éléments très positifs qui ont été
soulignés avec beaucoup d'éclairage
pertinents je voudrais simplement
revenir rapidement sur la trajectoire
récente de nos finances publiques qui
montre que la stratégie que sue le
gouvernement et la bonne dans un tel
contexte
premier élément de réflexion je serai
partager avec vous il s'agit de la mise
en lumière de l'art éviter la réduction
prévue du déficit public en 2010 plus
importante que prévu et qui témoigne du
fait que les efforts du gouvernement
vont dans la bonne direction
l'année 2010 comme vous le savez s'est
achevée sur un déficit public de l'ordre
de 7 points de notre richesse nationale
il s'agit d'une amélioration
substantielle par rapport à l'objectif
de départ retenu dans la loi de finances
initiale pour l'année 2010 qui était je
le rappelle établi à huit et demi pour
cent du pib
et lors de la présentation du projet de
loi de finances pour 2011 la prévision
du déficit public pour 2010 avait été
une première fois révisé à la baisse à
7,7 et nous atterrissons à 7 points du
pib
c'est dire cette réduction est cette
trajectoire est donc c'est dire si
l'addition des mesures qui vous ont été
proposés qui ont d'ailleurs à certains
égards nourrit des débats par ailleurs
de qualité même s'il était souligné de
manière à nîmes et nous ont permis de
montrer que cette trajectoire était la
bonne et surtout d'être avec un temps
d'avancé au rendez-vous qui font partie
de nos engagements vis-à-vis notamment
nos partenaires européens ou des
investisseurs comme l'a évoqué christine
lagarde
la date notifié à la commission
européenne reflète cette amélioration
elle s'établit pour l'année dernière à
81 7% du pib contre 82,9 % prévus au
moment du dernier projet de loi de
finances ces bons résultats sont dus à
plusieurs facteurs parmi les principaux
je citerai une reprise de l'économie et
de l'emploi plus dynamique que ce qui
avait été escomptée ministre de
l'économie a évoqué des chiffres du
chômage qui sont tombés aujourd'hui qui
montre là encore la continuité de
l'effort poursuivi en matière de
création d'emplois d'une part et de
réduction du chômage d'autre part un
coup par ailleurs de la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle en 2010 moins élevé
que les prévisions et enfin le résultat
d'un effort collectif de la part de
l'ensemble des acteurs de la dépense
publique l'an dernier nous avons tenu
notre engagement de maîtrise des
dépenses de l'état nous respectons
strictement le plafond autorisé et la
norme de dépense qui a été construite
sur une base de progression strictement
limitée à l'inflation
le zéro volume et c'était évidemment ma
première responsabilité en tant que
ministre du budget et c'est la première
règle budgétaire ne pas dépenser un euro
de plus que l'autorisation donnée par le
parlement ce contrat et on prie je
rappelle au passage que ce plafond de
dépenses a été construit sur le
fondement d'une prévision d'inflation de
1 2% pour 2010 en réalité la l'inflation
a été de 1,5 pour cent le plafond
n'ayant pas été revus à la hausse cela
représente
rétrospectivement une moindre dépense
d'environ un milliard d'euros
là encore je tiens à souligner devant
vous à travers ce débat les efforts
poursuivis en la matière de ne pas
dériver de cette trajectoire que nous
nous sommes imposés par ailleurs
l'effort collectif réalisé en 2010 se
traduit par une meilleure maîtrise des
dépenses sociales et en particulier les
dépenses d'assurance maladie pour la
première fois en effet est il besoin de
le redire mais après tout la répartition
est l'une des premières
la pédagogie depuis 97 l'objectif
national de dépenses d'assurance maladie
a été tenue il était fixé à 3% en 2010
il a été établi à 2 9% pour cette année
enfin il me semble important surtout
devant la haute assemblée de préciser
que les collectivités locales ont
participé à cet effort global de manière
non négligeable
ou bien la modération de leurs
investissements tout cela explique les
résultats meilleurs que nous avons
obtenus en matière de réduction de nos
déficits publics
deuxième sujet que je souhaite aborder
devant vous portent sur le programme de
stabilité en tant que tel et qui
s'inscrit résolument dans le
prolongement de cette stratégie que nous
venons de développer devant vous une
stratégie qui est fondée sur la
combinaison d'une maîtrise stricte et
durable de la dépense publique et de
réformes porteuses de croissance le
gouvernement en effet déterminé à être
au rendez vous des engagements qu'il a
pris devant vous et qui sont inscrits
dans la loi de programmation des
finances publiques
notre objectif est de ramener le déficit
public en deçà de 3% en 2013
et pour y parvenir à l'automne dernier
nous nous étions fixé un calendrier
clair un déficit public à 6% du pib en
si les huissiers sous votre autorité
monsieur le président avec amabilité de
ne pas trop parler trop fort puisque
nous sommes les plus près par le
tropisme naturel de cette expression
public à 4,6 pour cent en 2012 à 3% en
2013 et 2% en 2014
compte tenu du déficit moins important
que prévu pour l'année 2010 c'est du
sérieux avec lequel nous avons préparé
avec vous les textes financiers pour
2011 voté à l'automne 2010 nous sommes
en mesure de révisée favorablement notre
prévision pour cette année et ce dès
aujourd'hui nous sommes donc fixé un
nouvel objectif de 5,7 pour cent de
déficit public pour 2011 ce nouveau show
ya atteindre n'aurait paix mais
répercute pas l'ensemble des 07 points
de richesse nationale
car une partie de cette amélioration est
liée à des effets
reconductible les années suivantes comme
c'est par exemple le cas de la révision
du coût de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle nous l'avons longuement
développé je n'y reviens pas pour
l'année prochaine nous avons souhaité
maintenir notre objectif de déficit
public à 4,6 pour cent du pib
les bons résultats obtenus en matière de
réduction des déficits nous permettent
d'éviter de prendre des mesures
complémentaires pour compenser la légère
révision à la baisse de l'hypothèse de
croissance pour 2012 qui passe de 2,5
pour cent dans la loi de programmation à
2,25 dans le programme de stabilité qui
vous est proposé aujourd'hui comme nous
l'avons promis nous tiendront chaque
année nos engagements jusqu'en 2013 mais
pour autant il n'est pas question de
précipiter le rythme de réduction des
déficits publics l'effort exigé des
français déjà considérable nous en avons
conscience et le gouvernement
nous l'avons longuement et longuement
développées au cours de nos débats à
travers la loi de finances 2011 ne
serait pas là croître à nouveau ce qui
signifierait de renoncer à protéger
notamment les publics des plus fragiles
et prendre surtout le risque de casser
un siècle de croissance encore
convalescent nous demeurons donc en
ligne avec nos engagements pris aux lois
de programmation des finances publiques
troisième élément de réflexion et
troisième positions que le gouvernement
soutient devant vous aujourd'hui
le projet de loi de finances pour 2012
sera construit dans le strict respect du
budget triennal 2011-2013 dont il
constitue la deuxième en huit et ce
budget contribuer de manière décisive au
redressement des finances publiques
puisqu'il a été élaborée dans le respect
d'une double norme de dépense qui fait
d'ailleurs l'objet d'un article dédié de
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques sur la période 2011-2014 d'une
barge rappelle la stabilisation en euros
courants le fameux zéro valeur des
crédits budgétaires et des prélèvements
sur recettes au profit de l'union
européenne
ainsi des collectivités locales hors
charges de la dette et des pensions des
fonctionnaires de l'état nous assumons
le passé mais nous fixions une
stabilisation des dépenses dire qu'on ne
fera pas le coup de la ville dans le
cadre du déroulé de cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques
deuxième
point une augmentation annuelle des
crédits qui sera toujours au maximum
égale à l'inflation
c'est le zéro volume sur le périmètre de
la nomme normes élargi chaque année
c'est donc la norme la plus
contraignante qui s'appliquera le non
remplacement d'un départ à la retraite
sur deux sera poursuivie en 2012 cela se
traduira par la suppression d'environ
30000 emplois à temps plein l'objectif
triennal de réduction des dépenses de
fonctionnement et d'intervention de 10 %
sur trois ans appliquera une diminution
de 2 et demi pour cent pour l'année
prochaine après une baisse de 5% en 2011
là encore nous ne nous éloignons pas de
la trajectoire des engagements et je me
rappelle du vote de la représentation
nationale de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques sur cette période
2011 2014
par ailleurs comme en 2011 l'ensemble
des concours de l'état aux collectivités
locales seront stabilisés en valeur
à l'exception du fonds de compensation
de la tva lequel connaît une dynamique
autonome c'est un point important je
rappelle qu'à ressortir le fctva de
cette norme de gel des dotations de
l'état vis-à-vis des collectivités
territoriales c'est favoriser le
maintien l'amplification l'accélération
claire l'autonomie des collectivités
territoriales dans une logique
d'investissement
là encore ce sera précieux est utile
pour irriguer l'économie sur l'ensemble
de notre territoire
les dépenses des autres administrations
de sécurité sociale seront elles aussi
contenue en lien avec la montée en
charge progressive de la réforme des
retraites
corrigé des revalorisations la tendance
des prestations vieillesse va
effectivement grandement décéléré au
cours des années à venir
+1 8% en moyenne annuelle pour la
période 2012 2014 et contre 2,8 pour
cent pour 2010 et 2011
je ne détaillerai pas le volet recettes
du programme de stabilité que nous vous
soumettons aujourd'hui je veux
simplement rappeler à ce titre les
engagements du gouvernement sur lesquels
nous ne transigerons pas à une
augmentation généralisée des impôts une
réforme de la fiscalité du patrimoine
qui sera neutre pour les recettes
fiscales de l'état sur l'ensemble de la
période et une hausse des recettes
résultant essentiellement comme
christine lagarde a évoqué de la reprise
de l'activité et de la réduction des
dispositifs fiscaux
dérogatoire au droit commun - là
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs comme vous
pouvez le constater au coeur de notre
programme de stabilité 2011 2014 il y
encore il y a toujours la poursuite
d'une stratégie de maîtrise des finances
publiques pour un retour rapide à
l'équilibré de nos comptes
l'objectif que le gouvernement s'est
assigné est inédit mais il est réaliste
dans la mesure où nous récoltons d'ores
et déjà les premiers fruits de cet
effort collectif ça donne de la
crédibilité aux propos que nous tenions
devant vous au nom du gouvernement
nous voulons pérenniser vous le savez
cette démarche en inscrivant dans la
constitution de nouvelles règles qui
viendront encadrer la gestion des
finances publiques
l'objectif du gouvernement est claire
inscrire nos efforts dans le long terme
garantir notre modèle social et notre
souveraineté nationale pour les
générations futures je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à philippe marini rapporteur général de
la commission des finances
le président madame le ministre monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
c'est l'an dernier en juillet 2010 que
pour la première fois nous nous sommes
exprimés par un vote afin de clôturer le
débat d'orientation des finances
publiques
ensuite en décembre de l'an dernier lors
de la discussion de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
2011 2014
nous avons obtenu le principe d'un vote
sur le programme de stabilité avant sa
transmission aux autorités
communautaires et dans le même esprit
si tout se passe comme on peut le
souhaiter
en ce qui concerne le cheminement du
projet de loi de révision
constitutionnelle sur la gouvernance des
finances publiques
le principe de ce vote devrait figurer
dans la constitution
cet élément n'est pas dans le texte
initial du gouvernement
mais il a fait l'objet d'un amendement
voté par la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale
et naturellement celle du sénat
s'associe à une telle initiative
il ne s'agit pas là de simples questions
de procédure mais nous sommes au plus
profond des enjeux politiques et du rôle
du parlement politiquement
économiquement le programme de stabilité
même s'il se présente de manière austère
et macro économique le programme de
stabilité c'est bien la norme supérieure
en matière de finances publiques
il faut que nous le réalisions davantage
il ya peut-être un élément formel qui
fait obstacle
c'est le fait que ce programme de
stabilité ce document qui nous est
soumis ce soir
et et formules et non pas en euros mais
dans une autre monnaie qui est le
dixième de point de pipe
c'est une expression plus abstraite
on peut naturellement passé et des
dixièmes de point de pipe aux milliards
d'euros courants mais il faut comprendre
qu'au niveau de l'union européenne
lorsqu'il s'agit de réaliser des
comparaisons sur les textes provenant
des différentes nations qui composent
l'union c'est bien la notion de point ou
deux dixièmes de point de pim et qui est
l'élément le plus neutre pour procéder à
de telles comparaisons je vous dis cela
parce que vous vous en souvenez mes
chers collègues lors de la discussion de
la loi de programmation en décembre nous
avions obtenu du gouvernement qu'il
veuille bien modifié le libellé de cette
loi de programmation qui dorénavant
s'exprime bien en milliards d'euros
courants temps en limite supérieure de
dépenses
quand efforts à réaliser en termes de
mesures nouvelles sur les recettes
il est essentiel mes chers collègues que
nous prenions bien conscience de ce
caractère de normes supérieures du texte
qui nous est soumis ce soir malgré son
expression abstraite et austère il est
important aussi du point de vue de
l'indépendance nationale et même de la
souveraineté nationale que nous prenions
cette décision ici au parlement français
avant que les autorités communautaires
expriment leur vision des choses et
leurs éventuelles observations et c'est
toute la logique de ce nouveau semestre
européen ka qu'augmenter très utilement
madame christine lagarde
dorénavant c'est en avril que commence
le cycle budgétaire au parlement et
nous le savons aussi ce projet de
programme de stabilité va être examiné
par les autorités communautaires et il
va revenir il va revenir en temps utile
pour la préparation des lois financières
annuelles loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale et loi de finances de
l'état mais il sera je le souligne
loisible aux assemblées parlementaires
de se saisir de ces retours sous la
forme par exemple cher président bizet
de résolution au sens de l'article 88-4
de la constitution
compte tenu de l'analyse qui aura été
fait par la commission européenne et le
conseil européen et le cas échéant des
des éléments d observation des
correctifs qui pourront apparaître à
l'issue d'un tel examen
naturellement ce présent programme de
stabilité est différent des autres il
est différent des autres pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que nous n'avons
plus droit au double langage à la vérité
nous n'avons jamais eu le droit de
pratiquer un double langage mais
néanmoins nous l'avons fait car ce que
nous disions à l'europe
nous ne le disons pas à nos concitoyens
et madame briques soyez équitable et
veuillez constater avec nous que le
présent programme de stabilité est
sensiblement meilleur un peu meilleur
que les précédents et coin
s'agissant de la période la plus récente
l'évolution qu'il trace est bien
conforme à la réalité et c'est
réellement la première fois même si une
alouette ne fait pas le printemps
et si cela ne nous donne pas de
certitude sur la réalisation
que nos finances publiques connaîtront
dans les années 2012 2013 et 2014 alors
il est clair que nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans une situation où deux puissants
d'incitation s'exercent pour que nous ne
saignons plus aux facilités et aux
délices du double langage que nous
étions trop habitués à pratiquer
quelques et était d'ailleurs les
formations politiques au gouvernement
je m'empresse de le rappeler car c'est
une affaire qui a commencé en 1999
et si autocritique il doit y avoir à mon
sens il serait bon qu'elle fut
collective
alors depuis un an en particulier
plusieurs puissantes incitations sont
apparus la première plus évidente c'est
la crise des dettes souveraines est tout
à fait clair que le couple coûte de
l'endettement proportion de
l'endettement par rapport à la richesse
nationale 2 min où on fait une matrice
elle figure dans le rapport écrit et on
voit où se situent les états qui
aujourd'hui sont en grande difficulté en
difficulté ou sur la sellette
cela se déduit simplement de la matrice
et il est tout à fait clair que la zone
euro sa soutenabilité dépend d'un
mécanisme de solidarité mises en place à
titre provisoire puis devant faire
l'objet à compter de 2013 d'un
dispositif pérenne mais il est non moins
clair que ce dispositif de solidarité
repose sur la crédibilité des grands
états du coeur de la zone euro et que
pour financer le mécanisme de solidarité
ils étaient 1
dispensable que ces grands états
bénéficient de la cotation la plus
favorable possible et du coût le plus
bas possible de notre endettement et
soyons zambien conscient mes chers
collègues lorsque nous nous battons pour
cela lorsque nous nous battons aux côtés
du gouvernement pour la convergence vers
les 3 % en 2013
non seulement nous défendons notre pays
contre les risques de dérives contre les
risques d'une nouvelle récession mais
nous défendons aussi la zone euro car
nous ne savons pas ce qu'il adviendrait
de nos économies réelles si nous vivions
un scénario de discontinuité en la
matière c'est un sujet essentiel et tout
dépend de la crédibilité de ce chemin de
convergence vers les 3 % et vers une
dette plafonnés à 60 % du produit
intérieur brut est rappelons le enfin
mes chers collègues en 2013
madame lagarde nous l'a indiqué en 2013
à la fin de 2013
nous atteindrons mais nous atteindrons
seulement le seuil au delà duquel la
dette en capital cessera d'augmenter
jusque là et quels que soient nos
efforts elle continuera mécaniquement
arithmétiquement inéluctablement à
progresser en termes de proportion de la
richesse nationale
parmi les incitations naturellement il y
a la réforme du pacte de stabilité
mais mme lagarde a rappelé le
cheminement institutionnels nous ne
savons pas quel sera son issue finale
je ne suis pas en ce qui me concerne un
grand admirateur des sanctions surtout
automatique surtout s'adressant à des
pays exsangue et à qui l'on demanderait
par hypothèse de payer sur des
ressources qu'elles ne peuvent plus
procuré des sommes très importantes qui
et mise en pension auprès des autres
états de l'union très sincèrement je ne
crois pas que de tels dispositifs
surtout présenté comme automatique
puisse appartenir au monde réel mais les
états seront assurément corriger ce
qu'il peut y avoir de trop doctrinaire
dans les approches de la commission vont
faire confiance aux cheminements
institutionnels pour parvenir à quelque
chose de raisonnable reste pas moins
qu'au bout du compte il y aura plus de
contraintes et que cela nous créera plus
de devoirs que par le passé enfin
troisième incitations c'est celle que
nous allons nous donner je l'espère par
la constitution et c'est un débat très
prochain auquel nous sommes conviés
il s'agira de prendre en compte année
par année en terme de plafonds de
dépenses en termes de mesures nouvelles
portant sur les recettes
les efforts à réaliser pour respecter la
trajectoire mais soyons très attentifs
mes chers collègues
cette règle de convergence ne sera
opérante que si les hypothèses
économiques sur lesquelles elle repose
que si ces hypothèses économiques sont
réalistes et nous entrons ici dans tout
un débat que la commission s'est efforcé
de traiter dans son rapport écrit nous
faisons référence car nous aussi vivons
à notre façon le semestre européen aux
déplacements que nous venons de réaliser
en grande bretagne où l'une des
premières initiatives du nouveau
gouvernement est de créer un office de
responsabilité budgétaire pour dire les
hypothèses économiques aux pays bas où
le bureau central de planification créé
après 1945 par jan tinbergen est
unanimement respecté et même par toutes
les formations politiques qui sont tenus
de passer par son crible
quand elle annonce des programmes
électoraux nous sommes également passé
par berlin où nous avons observé que le
gouvernement fédéral se conforment
toujours au consensus des
conjoncturistes
il y as si je ne me trompe une dizaine
d'instituts qui travaille très
régulièrement sur la conjoncture
allemande est systématiquement le
gouvernement prend la moyenne des
prévisions issus de ce groupe de
conjoncturistes
et sincèrement madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre nous persistons à
penser que la fixation du taux de
croissance par le gouvernement n'est
qu'une apparence n'est ce pas et que
c'est une sorte de khalis dont il
vaudrait mieux que vous soyez un peu
détournée prenant pour établir les
documents budgétaires des hypothèses à
la fois prudente et neutre et en ce qui
nous concerne
n'ayant pas beaucoup d'imagination nous
pensons toujours que le taux de
croissance potentielle de l'économie
c'est-à-dire 2% et le taux le plus
neutre par construction que l'on puisse
trouver dans un tel équilibre pluri
annuel rapport au programme de stabilité
de l'an dernier plusieurs progrès réels
ont été faits d'abord et les hypothèses
d'élasticité des recettes sont un peu
plus prudents et spa 1,1 pour cent par
rapport au pib au lieu de 1,2 pour cent
c'est une marge de prudence qu'il
convient de souligner et s'agissant des
autres observations que nous avons que
nous avions faites et elles doivent être
réitérée en ce qui concerne le taux de
croissance et je viens de le faire elles
doivent être également réitéré pour une
part en ce qui concerne l'hypothèse
d'évolution des dépenses munich
il est bien vrai que le taux de 0 6% en
volume est très volontariste mais il est
non moins vrai qu'il s'est vérifié pour
la première fois en 2010 il s'est
vérifié pour des raisons diverses pour
une part exceptionnelle fin du plan de
relance et modération des
investissements des collectivités
territoriales mais il s'est vérifié
aussi faut pas hésiter à le dire parce
que l'évolution de l'ondam est plus
raisonnable et parce que la réforme des
retraites commence où va commencer à
porter ses effets également bien sûr
parce que l'état a été plus raisonnable
plus rigoureux en ce qui concerne la
gestion des dépenses des ministères
donc nous abordons avec intérêt cet
exercice de prévision tout en observant
que pour une part et pour les années
2012 2013 2014 la réduction du trend la
réduction de la tendance
plus exactement d'évolution de défense 8
n'est pas complètement documenté n'est
ce pas comme ceux ci ressort du rapport
écrit et à hauteur de 0,5 0,7 point de
pib
il demeure des espaces d'incertitude ou
des zones d'ombré et il est très
vraisemblable que le gouvernement sera
amené à préciser cela notamment si la
commission européenne le lui demande
alors à ce stade
que peut-on dire en prévision de l'année
et j'avais lu avec grand intérêt des
déclarations faites par le ministre du
budget et tout début avril
je n'oserais dire que c'était par eu un
1er avril
et concernant les efforts
supplémentaires à faire et qu'il
chiffrait à 6 milliards d'euros
dans l'hypothèse d'un taux de croissance
de 2% au cours de l'année 2012
la commission des finances a fait jouer
une série de paramètres on trouvera cela
dans notre rapport est notre zone
s'agissant de l'ordre de grandeur des
efforts supplémentaires à faire se situe
entre 6 et 10 milliards d'euros
mais nous tenons le même raisonnement et
il est assez naturel que la commission
des finances s'efforce d'être
particulièrement prudente car si nous ne
l'étions pas qu'ils le seraient dans
notre république mes chers collègues
donc
et s'il y a un regret à émettre c'est
que l'on n'ait pas anticipé dès
aujourd'hui cette évolution qui paraît
très vraisemblable au demeurant à
l'automne prochain
ce ne sera pas une décision plus
agréable et plus facile et si l'on se
trompe dans le sens du pessimisme ce
serait au contraire est un élément
politiquement très porteur madame le
ministre monsieur le ministre que de
dire que la conjoncture permet
d'atténuer des efforts déjà annoncées au
total et mes chers collègues ce document
mérite tout notre intérêt sur le plan
méthodologique sur le plan technique et
en tant qu il témoigne d'une volonté de
convergence et de crédibilité
et puisque l'année 2012 sera une année
tout à fait exceptionnelle une année
charnière
il est essentiel et je crois que ce sera
à la fois l'honneur de ce gouvernement
et l'honneur de la majorité
parlementaire qui le soutient que la loi
de finances loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale de 2012 soit des
documents particulièrement sérieux
crédible
inattaquable car c'est assurément sur le
terrain de la crédibilité du respect de
la vérité et de la parole donné que
beaucoup de choses se joueront en 2012
merci de votre attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
alors j'indique au sénat que compte tenu
de l'organisation du débat décidé par la
conférence des présidents
les temps de parole dont disposent les
groupes pour cette discussion sont les
suivants le groupe pour l'union pour un
mouvement populaire 33 minutes le groupe
socialiste 26 minutes l'union centriste
dix minutes
le groupe crc spg dix minutes le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique social 8
minutes et la réunion administrative des
sénateurs ne figurant sa liste aucun
groupe 3 minutes dans la suite du débat
la parole est aux orateurs des groupes
et je donne la parole à madame la
présidente nicole borvo cohen seat
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues comme nous ne sommes pas au
conseil d'administration de l'entreprise
france mais au parlement
je dirais politiquement ce que nous
pensons de votre programme de stabilité
programme de stabilité encore
faudrait-il s'accorder sur le diagnostic
l'europe est malade profondément en
crise elle est malade des politiques
ultralibérales mené depuis des années et
de leurs conséquences pour les peuples
les banques les capitaux les gros
actionnaires se porte bien
or ce que vous proposez c'est de
continuer à satisfaire les marchés en
imposant toujours plus d'austérité aux
peuples européens et toujours moins de
solidarité à l'égard des peuples et des
pays par exemple de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
avec des migrants tunisiens et honteux
au lieu de conjuguer efforts et moyens
pour faire face à une immigration
exceptionnel d'ailleurs limités en
nombre sans doute provisoire
les gouvernements actuels et par voie de
conséquence l'union européenne font la
démonstration qu'ils ne sont capables
que de démagogie et d'irresponsabilité
puisqu'ils ne font que distiller la peur
et le rejet dans les conséquences
politiques on le sait sont de plus en
plus inquiétante
pour en revenir à votre projet nous le
présenter aujourd'hui en sollicitant
l'avis des groupes parlementaires avant
de soumettre à la commission européenne
le document dont vous avez tracé les
grandes lignes également appelée
programme national de réforme 2011 2013
vise à évaluer la conformité de nos
politiques publiques avec le pacte de
compétitivité franco allemand et autre
pacte pour l'euro
or la discussion que nous avons ce soir
anticipe sur une disposition notre
projet de loi constitutionnel déposé
devant l'assemblée nationale examine et
très prochainement relatif à l'équilibré
des finances publiques
celle ci prévoit en effet que le
parlement puisse préalablement donné son
avis sur le contenu de ce programme
notre débat en apportant que les
apparences de la démocratie
en réalité cette nouvelle façon de
procéder qui consiste à discuter dès
maintenant des grandes orientations
budgétaires et sociales du gouvernement
afin d'obtenir le feu vert de la
commission a pour seul objectif de faire
cautionner par le parlement l'abandon de
la souveraineté nationale sur la
politique économique et sociale de notre
pays
ceux-ci figure clairement dans les
conclusions du dernier conseil européen
des 24 et 25 mars dernier j'en cite un
passage dans le cadre de la mise en
oeuvre de ces politiques et pour obtenir
une large adhésion à ce processus les
parlements nationaux les partenaires
sociaux les régions et d'autres parties
prenantes
ils seront pleinement associés très bien
cette nouvelle pratique découle
directement de graves décisions prises
lors du conseil européen totalement
éclipsé d'ailleurs à ce moment là par la
situation en libye
désormais en europe chaque gouvernement
sera tenu de soumettre son budget dès le
mois d'avril aux membres de la
commission
à charge pour ceux ci de proposer les
recommandations que les parlements
nationaux seront fortement incités à
suivre avant le vote de leur propre
budget un pays qui ne respecteraient pas
cette discipline budgétaire aveugle
s'exposerait alors à des sanctions
financières en outre chaque pays sera
tenus d'inscrire dans sa législation
nationale le plafond de déficit public à
ne pas dépasser
c'est donc pour cette raison que vous
prévoyez en france de grave et
l'interdiction des déficits publics dans
le marbre de la constitution
c'est une piètre parade vous l'avouerez
pour empêcher toute alternative à votre
politique
d'un commun accord entre les
gouvernements européens la commission
s'est ainsi vu attribuer le pouvoir
exorbitant d'examiner les projets
budgétaires nationaux pluriannuel selon
les seuls critères de l' équilibre
financier et de la lutte contre les
déficits publics qui sont avec la libre
concurrence les principaux piliers du
dogme libéral s'est une fois de plus un
grave abandon de souveraineté est un
déni de démocratie
cette réunion du conseil européen a
marqué un inquiétant tournant dans
l'histoire de la construction européenne
il s'agit d'un pas de plus vers une
europe fédérale la direction autoritaire
toujours plus imprégné l'idéologie
ultralibérale on peut même considérer
que le 25 mai dernier l'europe a
subrepticement changer de projet et cela
en toute opacité
en effet en adoptant ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler le pacte pour l'euro
les dirigeants européens ont mis sur
pied une politique qui vise à
contraindre leurs gouvernements
respectifs à prendre des mesures
antisociales
que ce soit en matière de politique
salariale avec la suppression du
principe d'indexation des salaires sur
les prix avec la précarisation des
salariés organisée avec la flexisécurité
ou bien encore la réduction des
allocations chômage on voit poindre de
nouvelles réductions des retraites au
moyen de l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation et du recul mécanique de
l'âge de départ le contre-feu du
président de la république une année
charnière dont parlait notre rapporteur
qui a sorti de son chapeau le prime
inégalitaire et aux contours mal définis
dont on connaît pas très bien les monts
le montant pour les salariés des
entreprises qui augmentent les
dividendes versés à leurs actionnaires
7ce contre-feu en quelque sorte ne peut
faire illusion ce que vivent les
salariés c'est de blocage des salaires
des fonctionnaires par exemple une
augmentation du smic a minima alors que
les prix les prix des produits courant
indispensable augmente de façon
inquiétante
toutes ces mesures sont liées cohérente
elles font partie du même ensemble car
votre politique est conforme aux divers
pacte et autres plans d'austérité
concoctée avec la chancelière allemande
lors des derniers conseils européens
ces pactes sont présentés comme étant la
seule solution pour faire face à la
crise financière dont la
financiarisation de l'économie est
responsable et dont les salariés font
les frais ceux des pays débiteurs qui
supporteront le coût des prêts et
irresponsable consentis aux banques par
les états créanciers
monsieur mario draghi pressenti pour
présider la bce
ancien vice-président de la banque
goldman sachs particulièrement impliqués
dans la crise de 2008 est bien placé
pour le savoir
c'est socialement injuste et totalement
contraire à la défense de l'intérêt
général dont se prévalent volontiers nos
démocraties européennes la religion qui
inspire les mesures de votre programme
stabilité et de croissance
je préfère d'ailleurs employé le mot
austérité repose sur l'hypothétique
amélioration de notre compétitivité
économique
c'est un profond changement avec la
conception fondée sur le développement
par le progrès qui était en 2000 celle
de l'agenda de lisbonne aujourd'hui plus
question objectifs concrets de progrès
qu'il soit économique social ou culturel
seul compte l'impératif de la
compétitivité fondée sur quoi sur les
seuls critères de rentabilité
ces pactes rendent sceptiques les
peuples d'europe et six sites souvent de
fortes oppositions comme l'a encore
démontré la récente euromanifestation de
budapest
les populations sont lucides elles
comprennent que ces mauvaises réponses à
la crise financière a baisseront leur
niveau de vie heureusement les
inégalités développeront le travail
précaire et au total accentueront la
mise en concurrence des salariés des
différents pays ce qui est
le but recherché contre l'injustice
sociale qui porte en lui le programme de
stabilité que vous nous avez présenté
sera à coup sûr économiquement
inefficace inefficace car contraire à la
croissance en effet les règles qu'ils
posent en matière de fixation des
salaires en refusant d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat ne peuvent que brider la
croissance en nous proposant ces mesures
vous alignez sans sourciller sur les
désastreuse politique conduite depuis
dix ans par la commission et la banque
centrale européenne j'en ai dénoncé les
conséquences économiques et sociales
nous les vivons tous les jours mais en
matière de croissance dans la zone euro
le résultat par rapport à d'autres
régions du monde est tout aussi
calamiteux or voici que maintenant trois
pays de cette zone sont au bord d'une
faillite qui risque de s'étendre à
d'autres pays importe plus important le
plan de sauvetage de la grèce ne
fonctionne pas et le portugal bien être
sommé par des marchés financiers qui
refuse de prendre des risques de se
tourner vers l'europe et le fmi
au lieu de vous interroger face à cette
situation angoissante et d'examiner s'il
ne conviendrait pas de changer
radicalement l'orientation de la
politique monétaire de la politique
budgétaire vous persistez vous suivez de
thin man la commission et la banque
centrale européenne qu'ils ne veulent
pas remettre en cause des principes
qu'ils ont largement contribué à la
crise enfin avec des instruments
permettant d'imposer l'austérité dont il
s'est doté le dernier conseil a en
définitive décider en catimini d'aller
au delà du traité de lisbonne en le
modifiant par révision simplifiée c'est
à dire sans consultation des parlements
nationaux ni des citoyens
notre programme de stabilité n'est que
la déclinaison française les décisions
prises ailleurs elle appauvrissent les
peuples et accentuent leur défiance à
l'égard de la politique et des
institutions européennes comme viennent
à nouveau de le montrer les élections
finlande par exemple elle risque aussi
de les jeter dans les bras des
eurosceptiques et de l'extrême droite
pour notre part nous
un autre projet une autre logique je
n'en évoquerait que la mesure une mesure
importante qui me paraît aujourd'hui à
être intéressante
elle consiste en la création d'un fonds
européen de développement social destiné
à financer à taux très bas ou nuls des
investissements publics créateurs
d'emplois développant la formation la
recherche les services publics les
infrastructures et des réalisations en
matière d'environnement pour se dégager
de l'emprise étouffante les marchés
financiers ce fonds devrait pouvoir
utiliser la compétence de la bce à créer
de la monnaie afin de lui éviter de se
soumettre aux exigences spéculative des
investisseurs tels sont madame la
ministre monsieur ministre les
motivations profondes de notre groupe
pour voter résolument contre le projet
de programme de stabilité que vous nous
avez brièvement présenté merci
présidente et la parole est à denis
badré pour l'union centriste
jours
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la séance qui nous réunit ce soir est
historique
monsieur le ministre vous avez choisi
vous avez choisi monsieur le ministre
souligné d'entrée un instant combien du
sens pour la france comme pour l'europe
l'engagement conjoint et sur la nel de
l'exécutif et du parlement français sur
la transmission de notre programme
pluriannuel à bruxelles le parlement
donc va se prononcer sur le programme de
stabilité que le gouvernement envoie un
bruxelles le sénat à la parole pour se
prononcer ça lui sera plus facile que
moi sur cet acte qui engage le pilotage
pluriannuel de nos finances publiques
et bien sûr par voie de conséquence la
préparation du budget annuel prévu par
l'article 121 du traité sur l'union
européenne la transmission des
programmes de stabilité est un jalon
essentiel de l'information que la france
donne de l'état de son économie et de
ses finances la commission européenne et
puisque nous sommes liés g16 dans une
démarche intergouvernementale éléments
que nous donnons j'ose dire en premier
lieu à nos partenaires européens
le programme pluriannuel 2011-2014
innove à la fois sur la forme sur le
fond
au plan de la forme d'abord le groupe de
l'union centriste se félicite de
l'engagement pris par le gouvernement de
soumettre ce programme au vote du
parlement et se félicitent les vous en
remercie la séance de ce soir donne un
avant-goût des dispositions prévues par
le projet de loi constitutionnelle
relatif à l'équilibré des finances
publiques
cette pratique ne peut que renforcer le
chaînage vertueux des finances publiques
avant même qu'on entre dans le cycle qui
inaugurera le collectif budgétaire du
printemps
c'est un gage de plus grande lisibilité
des perspectives financières du pays et
madame borvo j'ose le dire de meilleure
démocratie puisque vous en parlais à
l'instant le principe du consentement à
l'impôt
même lorsque nous sommes liés à 27 doit
rester une base de la démocratie on s'en
donne les moyens ici nous innovons
ensuite sur le fond je note avec quelle
prudence le gouvernement a modifié ses
prévisions de croissance pour 2011 et
nous les prévisions fixées
respectivement 2 et 2,25 pour cent
semblent fondées sur une analyse
relativement réaliste des performances
économiques du pays
le rapporteur général parlait à
l'instant d'être les plus neutres et je
pense que c'était bien je veux saluer
ici le travail réalisé par notre
rapporteur général philippe marini
son rap dans son rapport sur la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle la
commission des finances du sénat a très
justement pointé les failles et les
limites des programmations
pluriannuelles qu'elles soient
nationales ou européennes sans une
hypothèse de croissance crédibles et
solides
aucun gouvernement ne saurait avoir une
estimation fiable de ses recettes et
sans objectif au plafond de dépenses
aucun gouvernement ne serait assainir
durablement ses finances publiques
ce qu'on pourrait appeler le risque
budgétaire est désormais largement
répandue dans les pays occidentaux
il pèse aussi directement et
indirectement sur la france
l'heure n'est plus aux déclarations
d'intention aux présentations optimiste
il nous faut faire preuve aujourd'hui
d'une responsabilité 13 d'une
responsabilité très engagé en matière de
finances publiques
il y a un an presque jour pour jour les
européens étaient au chevet de nos amis
grecs dont la dette publique faisait
alors l'objet d'attaqués spéculatives
assez largement justifié d'ailleurs
l'irlande dès l'automne elle aussi vu sa
dette souveraine l'entraîner dans la
crise le portugal est dans la tourmente
sans perspectives financières encore
vraiment restaurer on craint que
d'autres suivent comme disait le
fabuliste ils ne mouraient pas tous mais
tous étaient atteints heureusement
solidarité oblige personne ne meurt et
c'est d'abord aux spéculateurs que nous
avons déclaré la guerre en affichant une
solidarité européenne sans faille
la contrepartie de cette solidarité est
évidemment un droit de regard mutuelle
et une rigueur partager à ce titre la
france ce doit être exemplaire
c'est malheureusement pas encore tout à
fait le cas nous n'avons pas vote nous
n'avons pas voté un seul budget en
équilibre depuis soixante-quinze la
limite de 3% du pipe fixées à l'article
126 du traité sur l'union européenne
étaient respectées qu'une année sur deux
au cours de la dernière décennie
en 2010 le déficit public a dépassé le
triste record des 7 % fib
dépassant 130 milliards d'euros
projetant notre dette publique au delà
de 87% du pipe dès l'an prochain
la france vit à crédit sur le compte sur
le compte de ses enfants et ses
petits-enfants
nous perdons en crédibilité vis-à-vis de
nos partenaires européens comme des
marchés financiers je ne voudrais pas
que nous attendions que la note de notre
signature soit dégradée pour que nous
prenions les mesures adéquates pour agir
les états unis eau mais eux mêmes ne
semblent plus à l'abri du risque
souverain
l'administration du président du
président obama se prépare à de grandes
difficultés pour le vote du budget
américain
au risque de remettre en cause lui 100
mille emplois de fonction à travers le
pays alors que les inscriptions dans les
agences de recherche d'emploi en tata
aux etats-unis le record historique en
mars dernier le froncement de sourcil
agences de notation peut faire trembler
wall street
le service de la dette américaine qui
couvre près de 14 milliards de dollars
est aujourd'hui suspendue au jugement de
l'agent standaard en bourse
si même la première économie mondiale
n'est plus à l'abri lancera-t-il de nous
de la france et de l'europe en dehors de
laquelle il existe peu de salut pour
notre pays la stabilité économique et
budgétaire en europe ne se décrète pas
le se construit dans une concertation
renforcée et c'est dans cette
perspective que les parlements nationaux
de l'union européenne
aussi doivent orienter leurs efforts
conjoints le vote du budget évidemment
une prérogative nationale c'est notre
devoir et notre responsabilité d'élus
que d'être vigilants quant à l'emploi
des deniers publics
sept ans aux prérogatives ne peut être
transférée à la commission au parlement
européen simplement cette évidence ne
peut plus nous dispenser d'adopter une
attitude de solidarité européenne de
solidarité face à la crise et de
solidarité dans la prévention de la
crise l'entrée en vigueur du traité de
lisbonne nous a donné l'occasion de
renforcer les dispositions prévues au
titre casse de notre constitution les
articles 88,4 et 88,6 philippe magnan
temps d'un instant dans nos parlements
des prérogatives clair concernant le
contrôle du principe de subsidiarité
c'est normal et c'est est programmée il
faut aujourd'hui aller plus loin
considérant que des questions aussi
importantes et d'intérêt aussi européens
que la défense garantis des dettes
souveraines ou les budgets nationaux et
même les recettes du budget européen
donne lieu
à vote dans les parlements nationaux il
nous faut construire le réseau de ces
parlements nationaux qui avec le
parlement européen pour appréhender ces
questions et rendre compatible ambition
commune et prérogatives nationales
c'est vers une sorte d'écho fine
parlementaires qu'il faut aller j'ai eu
l'honneur de représenter notre
commission des finances à bruxelles lors
d'une récente rencontre semestre
européen organisé à l'initiative de la
commission économique du parlement
européen avec les commissions des
finances des parlements nationaux
ce fut très utile et très prometteur il
nous faudra poursuivre en allant plus
loin en envisageant notamment
d'éventuels forme de contrôle un
contrôle parlementaire concertée sera un
gage de lisibilité démocratie budgétaire
à offrir à l'europe alors le programme
de stabilité prendra son plein sens
c'est cette idée que je défendrai
notamment lors de la prochaine réunion
de la cosac où j'irai avec notre
collègue de gens disaient notamment que
je cherche à budapest dans quelques
jours avec cette question nous sommes
tout simplement en train de mettre en
musique l'article 5 du traité de
lisbonne qui est venu consacrer le rôle
des parlements nationaux dans la
construction européenne on n'avait sans
doute pas vu au moment du vote du traité
elle convient des gars il allait être
nécessaire ni ce que pourrait devenir la
portée de cet article voilà qui
représente une vraie exigence pour nos
parlements nationaux nous essayons de
nous en montrer dignes ce soir pour ce
qui nous concerne directement et un
nouveau ce soir il ne faut répondre à la
question de confiance posés par le
gouvernement au titre de l'article 50 1
de notre constitution nous allons
évidemment quand je dis nous il s'agit
du groupe de l'union centriste dire oui
la confiance est une denrée rare et
précieuse en ces temps d'instabilité
économique et financière et c'est dans
un esprit de confiance et de
responsabilité
les sénateurs centristes soutiendront le
gouvernement lors du scrutin en
approuvant la transmission à bruxelles
de ce programme de stabilité
non sans appeler je les dis le
gouvernement à faire encore beaucoup
mieux à l'avenir
je vous remercie et je suis arrivé aller
jusqu'au bout sans perdre totalement ma
voix
merci denis badré la parole est à nicole
bricq pour groupe socialiste jean nicol
c'est le président monsieur le
rapporteur général madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous entrons donc dans la procédure dite
du semestre européen
il s'agit de coordonner avant l'adoption
des budgets annuels nationaux ce qui
relativise encore plus l'exercice
budgétaire de la fin de l'année nous
devons donc coordonner les politiques
budgétaires et économiques en lien avec
le pacte de stabilité et la stratégie
europe 2020 qui s'éloigne au demeurant
fortement de la stratégie qui avait été
défini à lisbonne et le pacte de
stabilité est en ce moment même en débat
contradictoire pour le moins au
parlement européen ce qui peut nous
poser un petit problème de calendrier
puisque nous sommes censés nous
coordonner avec ce qui sortira des
débats du parlement et de la commission
selon la procédure européenne alors sur
la forme je ne consent à cela il ya un
progrès par rapport à l'année dernière
je rappelle que le premier ministre
avait adressé la trajectoire des
finances publiques en début d'année sous
forme d'un courrier alors que nous
n'avions débattu de la loi de
programmation qu'au début du mois de
novembre
quelques jours avant d'aborder la loi de
finances annuelles alors il pourrait
donc s'agir aujourd'hui comme l'a dit en
commission le rapporteur général d'une
actualisation de la loi de programmation
actualisation qu'il a qualifié par
ailleurs d' approximative j'y reviendrai
en réalité
il faut associer à cet exercice
l'examen que nous ferons en juin du
projet de loi constitutionnelle censée
fixer des règles d'or supposées
contraignantes pour réduire nos déficits
dès lors l'exercice a une portée toute
autre et revenant sur ce que la
commission européenne a proposé lors de
la présentation au conseil du semestre
européen
elle avait à l'époque pris soin
d'indiquer que je la cite le nouveau
cadre ne représentait en rien une limite
à la souveraineté des états nationaux
et pourtant c'est bien le président de
la banque centrale européenne qui
déclarait il n'y a guère que nous étions
dans une quasi fédération budgétaire
comprenne qui pourra alors fort bien
mais si tout cela se fait sous l'étroite
surveillance des marchés et madame la
ministre lors de la présentation devant
nos collègues de la commission des
finances à l'assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière vous avez bien insisté
et vous avez déclaré la france doit
impérativement défendre son triple à et
ça dans cet exercice se fait donc sous
l'oeil des marchés financiers mais je
voudrais insister sur un autre paramètre
madame la ministre est cher collègue qui
est quand même celui des peuples à qui
on va demander alors on peut se réjouir
on est dans des situations moins pires
que d'autres notamment quand on est un
peuple des états périphériques comme on
les appelle aujourd'hui mais à ces
peuples
on va demander
et deux portées essentiellement l'effort
de redressement
prenons garde mes chers collègues au
rocher qui se manifeste un peu partout
de l'idée même de l'europe
tout ce qui se passe chaque jour est en
train de déliter l'idée même de cette
europe unie alors une procédure
budgétaire fut-elle constitutionnaliser
peut-elle se substituer au choix
démocratique d'une politique et d'une
stratégie économique qui plus est à un
an d'une échéance que nous savons comme
cardinal l'élection présidentielle
certainement pas reconnaissons que
l'obstacle est de taille
quant à l'ampleur de nos déficits certes
la crise est passée par là et nous n'en
sommes pas encore sortis mais elle ne
saurait exonérer la majorité sortante de
ses responsabilités son bilan est
négatif je citerai peu de chief un
déficit public de 7% à la fin de 2010 il
était de 2,7
il ya quatre ans une dette multiplié par
deux en dix ans la cour des comptes
avait estimé à deux tiers l'impact des
choix budgétaires que vous avez opéré et
elle note dans son rapport annuel pour
2011 s'agissant de la trajectoire
2010-2013 que le déficit structurel qui
atteignait 5 % du petit banc 2009
s'était encore aggravée par les baisse
durable de prélèvements obligatoires qui
ne respectaient pas les règles de la loi
de programmation à peine celle ci voté
pour nous socialistes le rétablissement
des comptes publics est à la fois un
objectif de souveraineté politique et un
objectif de justice
nous ne pouvons pas l'ignorer pour le
présent et pour l'avenir
le coût des déficits que vous avez
accumulé sera difficile à résorber
encore faut-il articulé finement le
redressement économique
la justice fiscale et la responsabilité
terre or la trajectoire budgétaire que
vous proposez né sous tendu par aucune
stratégie économique
je veuille a insisté en 2007 vous aviez
fait le choix du paquet fiscal pour
disiez-vous alors libérer les énergies
de ceux qui parmi les plus aisés et est
susceptible selon vous de contribuer à
la croissance qu'il fallait aller
chercher avec les dents
on sait ce qu'il en fût une économie
rentière s'est substituée à une économie
productive et depuis lors vous avez vous
êtes en train de détricoter le paquet
fiscal sans pour autant substituer à
votre stratégie de 2007 une nouvelle
stratégie économique capable de
retrouver le chemin de la croissance
durable solide et créatrice d'emplois
pérennes
sans compter que les stratégies
budgétaires des pays voisins de la zone
euro convergent tel aussi vers
l'austérité ce qui accentuera la
faiblesse de la croissance et se faisant
compromettra leur établissement
budgétaire c'est le multiplicateur
keynésien à l'envers qui est à l'oeuvre
ces considérations macroéconomiques ne
sont pas superflus quand on voit que
l'hypothèse de croissance sur laquelle
repose la trajectoire que vous
transmettez est manifestement optimiste
ce qui ampute quelque peu sa crédibilité
vous avez je vais en dire un mot vous
avez seulement consenti à baisser votre
prévision d'un quart de point en 2012
or il s'agit de l'année de tous les
dangers et le consensus économique
tablent sur 1,8
pour cette année 2012 même rack ses
codes a publié ses chiffres en fin de
semaine dernière et il correspond à 1,8
alors vous vous programmez 2,25 en 2012
et à partir de et dès 2013 vous retenez
2,5 pour cent alors monsieur le
rapporteur général
j'ai entendu votre interpellation et se
laver un peu anticipée dans la
préparation de mon de mon petit tu
exposes et si ce chiffre a été avancé
par le ps
une faut préciser que son calendrier
n'est pas le même que le vôtre puisqu'il
s'agit de la période 2012 2017 alors le
gouvernement le gouvernement
je n'ai pas fini non non non non
attendez attendez on va parler des
recettes et des dépenses le gouvernement
fait comme si les clignotants étaient ou
devenez vers durablement dans votre
scénario
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
la consommation tiendra alors que le
pouvoir d'achat baisse
c'est désormais avéré l'amélioration des
exportations constaté comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure lors des derniers
prennent s2 2010 de 2010 par dans
deviendra structurelle
alors qu'elle est un effet de rattrapage
consécutif à l'effondrement de 2009 et
que l'évolution de notre commerce
extérieur sur la période de dix ans nous
fait perdre chaque année 0,4 point de
pib
les entreprises investiront les taux
d'intérêt seront modérément relever et
pour finir l'infra l'inflation ne sera
que conjoncturelle et le prix du baril
de pétrole devrait se stabiliser
et enfin les collectivités locales
sommet de s'ajuster à la nouvelle donne
fiscale et financière depuis 2010 me
diront leurs dépenses alors qu'elle
pourrait légitimement avoir des besoins
de financement en milieu de cycle
électoral je pense aux municipales et
monsieur le ministre vous vous êtes
satisfait tout à l'heure d'un chiffre
définitif du déficit pour 2010 2 7% au
lieu des 7 7 qui avait fait l'objet d' a
déjà d'un réajustement
je voudrais quand même vous rappeler
mais vous le savez très bien que les
collectivités locales ont contribué à la
moitié de la réduction du déficit en
2010 alors ce scénario madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre est un
conte mais il n'y aura ni faits ni
prince charmant et ce conte devrait nous
conduire à un assistant de 4.2 pipe et
pour satisfaire à la demande de
justifier du rapporteur général quatre
points de pete ça fait 80 milliards
alors que vous allez chercher en
pressurant la dépense et l'année
dernière je reviens à votre scénario je
vais parler des dépenses et des recettes
mais l'année dernière le rapporteur
général vous avez et nous l'avions
soutenu dans sa demande
vous avez posé une question je la
reprends en cas de variation à la baisse
de l'hypothèse de croissance qu'elle a
justement proposé vous une compression
supplémentaire des dépenses laquelle une
hausse des prélèvements et laquelle et
je crois qu'on peut vous reposez la même
question
cette année le rapport de la commission
chiffres par ailleurs une variation de 0
5 point à la baisse de la croissance à
une augmentation du ratio dépenses pim à
0 25 point
et si l'élasticité des recettes et moi
non l'impact sur le sol peut être double
j'en conclus que même si je suis pas là
pour parler à sa place mais que à la
lecture du rapport écrit que le
rapporteur n'est pas définitivement
comprend convaincu de la trajectoire qui
nous est proposé et il faut bien de plus
constaté que la documentation dont nous
disposons est très lacunaire
elle ne nous permet pas d'étayer la
crédibilité de votre trajectoire
ces lacunes se constate sur l'exécution
budgétaire 2010 et a fortiori sur les
années suivantes
mais il ressort des travaux du
rapporteur que s'agissant des dépenses
documenté l'objectif d'une croissance
des dépenses limitée à 0 6% n'est pas
vérifiée pour l'année 2011 et a fortiori
pour les années suivantes
le volet d nous quittons l'hémicycle du
sénat vous venez de suivre une partie de
la déclaration du gouvernement au
parlement sur le programme de stabilité
européen
dans ce programme la france s'engage à
réduire son déficit public à 3% du pib
d'ici à 2013
françois baroin ministre du budget a
d'ailleurs rappelé devant les sénateurs
que la france allait continuer de
maîtriser sa stratégie rapide des
dépenses publiques
quelle que soit la conjoncture
économique ce cette déclaration sera
soumise d'ici quelques instants
un vote du sénat avant d'être transmises
aux institutions européennes
je vous donne rendez vous aux demandes
sur notre antenne à 10h30 pour suivre
d'ailleurs à la suite de ce débat
en attendant je passe la main à nos
collègues lui lcp assemblée nationale et
je vous souhaite à tous une très bonne
soirée
bonsoir
non